hi doc yes how are you I was calling
because I had a blood test on Monday
after infection I had over the weekend
and the blood test
besides the leukocytes and all that
stuff which they said it was affected by
the infection they said that there might
be some kidney problem and they had an
elevated threatening yes that was
elevated to 1.64 and the GFR was low
they said of 42 okay well those aren't
too outrageous but it says that
something's going on okay how old are
you sir
so I mean okay do you have any other
issues any diabetes or high blood
pressure arthritis
no okay any skin problems any eczema or
psoriasis rosacea no any belly problems
constipation diarrhea or appendicitis
[Music]
summary confectional over the week
okay Charmaine you there I'm more okay
now David how much she weighs her woman
he's 180 180 pounds 70 years old and he
has two indicators that he's getting the
beginnings of kidney issues he has a
slightly elevated cranny's it should be
like 0.9 or 0.85 it's like one something
1.3 or whatever was and then he's got a
regis glomerular filtration rate GFR and
both of these indicate his filtering
units are not working like they should
and of course in most cases is because
there's not enough blood getting into
the filtration units and so what would
you do to help David support a healthy
kidney function to get all this straight
all those issues I would give him two
healthy Brandon heart packs I would add
the ultimate daily classic so nice and
plus and the vitamin d3 okay in it
ultimate nice and place you like that
one don't you
okay okay so chars exactly correct David
your body weight 280 pounds you need to
healthy brain and hard packs or months
to a healthy brain and heart pax romana
take a full dose of anything twice a day
and that's gonna support all the
biological functions in the body okay
and then you're also going to need and
char said I'd go ahead and get to two
bottles a month of the ultimate daily
classic tablets thing take three of
those twice a day and they support
healthy blood pressure and support
healthy blood flow into the kidneys and
it's through all obstructed arteries and
so you're going to get as a result
better kidney function because more
blood that goes into the kidneys a
better job it does and vitamin d3 can
help you absorb more minerals
particularly calcium and again also help
you the deposition of calcium into your
bones and so forth very good stuff and
then let's see here I think that got it
did I get it all correct or Charmaine oh
okay well then you want to be sure David
you cannot out supplement a bad diet so
the thing that's causing this is usually
a bad diet what what does he have to do
with his diner mean he needs to
eliminate all foods and oil no oil no
coconut all the margins no salad
dressings no mayonnaise no gluten no
wheat brentano's he can maximize the
absorption of nutrients and no processed
meats gotta go up those process means
things like deli slices of sandwich
meats sausage ham bacon Bologna salami
pastrami pepperoni jerky Carmody spam
all that's got to go and you know he can
have meat but it's got it's got to be
like roast or a steak or hamburger
cannot be burnt it has to be medium-rare
her and so forth okay give us a call
every couple of weeks
call us next time you get tested but
again it's a combination of stopping the
ongoing damage to the arteries feeding
blood into the kidneys and giving your
body what it needs to do is function